bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat alors que jean marc
ayrault le premier ministre a présenté
hier son plan d'investissement pour les
dix ans à venir afin de réaffirmer à les
ambitions écologiques du gouvernement
les sénateurs n'ont entendu ce matin
anne lauvergeon présidente de la
commission innovation 2030 sa mission
confiée par le gouvernement et
d'identifier les secteurs où la france
pourrait occuper une position dominante
d'ici à 2030 tout en privilégiant les
activités créatrices d'emplois pour
notre territoire
retour cet après midi à sur cette
audition bonjour à tous merci d'être
présent à cette audition
donc nous faisons en commun avec la
commission des affaires économiques
nous recevons aujourd'hui madame anne
lauvergeon qui est présidente de la
commission innovation 2030 alors la
commission innovation 2030 a été mise en
place par le président de la république
le 19 avril dernier
elle est composée de vingt personnalités
reconnues pour leurs compétences
industrielles scientifiques économistes
chercheurs qui madame sous votre
présidence ont été chargés de proposer
d'ici à l'été
les secteurs et les technologies où la
france est susceptible d'occuper des
positions de leader à l'horizon 2030
l'idée de faire émerger les champions de
demain dans les domaines utiles à la
société et prometteur en termes d'emploi
alors bien sûr à quelques semaines de
votre échéance vous n'allez pas tout
vous dire ça nous en sommes convaincus
mais bien sûr on pourrait peut-être ici
et de vous questionner et ça mes
collègues le ferons mais nous serions
heureux de savoir si on connaîtra la
date afin tout cas où en êtes-vous de
votre travail
comment vous avez procédé si vous avez
le sentiment que les leaders mondiaux
français bien sûr là n'existe mais est
ce qu'on avait pu les identifier et donc
dans quel dans quel temps on peut
espérer les voir apparaître donc sur la
scène est con
et industrielle et enfin quels sont
selon vous les secteurs les plus
porteurs pour les 20 prochaines années
je crois que c'est le minimum puisque
votre objectif c'est de nous éclairer
quand même étrange alors ainsi donc
notre commission sera je pense rassurer
puisque elle est créée depuis moins de
fête bio nan mais tout ce qu'il a
contribué à qui ce qui la constitue
ainsi que d'ailleurs la commission
économique sont déjà donc persuadé que
dans le domaine du développement durable
il y as je crois un champ d'avenir
important donc j'espère que nous
pourrons en parler
il est sûr que ce soit les énergies
renouvelables que ce soit le recyclage
des déchets que ce soit aussi une
optimisation des ressources
une plus grande efficacité énergétique
autant de champs qui sont porteurs
d'espoir en termes économiques alors
malheureusement notre pays traverse une
période où la confiance manque un petit
peu et je crois qu'un économie c'est
essentiel donc comment redonner
confiance à ce pays comment encourager
ses futurs leaders dont vous allez nous
parler et nous en remercions d'avancé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames messieurs ce président je crois
que dans votre exposé introductif vous
avez dit déjà énormément de choses je
vais essayer de répondre à toutes vos
questions
et puis ce que j'aimerais bien ce matin
si c'était possible en vous remerciant
de me donner l'occasion de cette
audition je souhaiterais que nous
puissions avec une partie de l'équipe du
rapporteur général vous écoutez écoutez
vos suggestions comment vous voyez les
choses comment voulez les santé pour
alors innovation 2030 on retient 2030 et
j'ai fait un petit test spontanée pour
beaucoup de gens 2030 c'est dans 30 en
2030 c'est donc 17 ans 17 ans à
l'échelle
industriels c'est à la fois très proche
et très loin si on fait cet exercice je
dirais de retour vers le passé
1996 et on peut prendre des grands
secteurs de notre industrie il n'y a pas
eu de modifications gigantesque depuis
1996 par contre nous avons connu la
révolution du numérique les évolutions
dans tout ce qui était les
communications systèmes d'information
donc on voit que suivant les secteurs
le rythme d'évolution est très différent
donc comment faire et c'est la question
qui nous a été posée par le président et
premier ministre
comment faire pour que nous ayons une
france en 2030 qui ne rate pas les
grandes innovations y compris les
innovations de rupture et une france
forte une france avec des emplois une
france avec un commerce un commerce
extérieur redresser donc c'est d'une
certaine façon une logique
d'anticipation dans lequel nous sommes
rentrés et là aussi si on se replonge
vers un passé qui n'est pas si ancien ce
passé qui a permis la construction de
nos grands champions industriels
aujourd'hui à l'époque c'était déjà une
logique d'anticipation
quand il a été décidé dans les années 70
au début des années soixante dix de
construire sur cinq grands secteurs 6
même les champions français pour faire
de la france une puissance industrielle
je rappelle le spatial l'aéronautique le
tgv les télécoms le nucléaire et puis le
plan calcul
or quand on regarde ya eu un échec sur 6
ce qui est quand même un taux de
réussite fantastique et c'est ça qui
nous a permis de construire les grandes
entreprises industrielles qui sont les
numéros un mondiaux ou numéros 2
mondiaux français
si on se re plonger encore plus dans le
passé c'est la création d'elf
et de total qui ont été effectivement
une volonté forte des pouvoirs publics
donc le nous avons été mandatés le 8
avril dernier comme vous le rappeliez
monsieur le président pour présenter
proposé d'abord de créer une commission
alors nous sommes 20 nous travaillons de
manière extrêmement collégiale et les
vingt personnes qui sont cette
commission je dois dire que on m'a
laissé carte blanche pour choisir au
moins 80% d'entre eux on essaie de faire
une commission extrêmement de gens
extrêmement différents ayant des points
de vue différents sur les choses ayant
des expériences différentes
donc ça va d'un philosophe michel serres
j'ai pas si vous avez lu son livre sur
le pouce et comment ceux ci transformait
nos enfants jusqu'à des gens qui
viennent du marketing en passant par des
innovateurs c'est à dire des gens qui
eux mêmes ont été jusqu'au bout de leurs
de leurs projets des industriels des
économistes donc finalement des gens
extrêmement différent et on nous a
demandé de faire des choix
alors pourrait se demander pourquoi on
demande et une collation de faire des
choix après tout l'état peut en faire
c'est très difficile je crois pour
l'état aujourd'hui de faire des choix
parce que il y a une
il y a des demandes extrêmement
nombreuse il ya des forces qui sont des
forces qui se dit ce fonds qui se font
jour pour tous et tel ou tel projet est
donc faire des choix rationnels et quand
même parfois extrêmement difficile
or on ne peut pas tout faire tout le
temps et surtout et c'est sa deuxième
question qui nous est posée comment
faire pour que l'état et une politique
de long terme
comment faire pour éviter qu on dirait
des jeux 2 ap comment faire pour que et
on le sait les réussites grande réussite
d'entreprises industrielles
technologiques sociétal pas ça ne marche
que quand on est sur le temps long donc
comment on retrouve le sens du temps
long alors ça ça sera une deuxième
partie de la commande qui nous est faite
associé d'une troisième partie qui est
quelle méthode utiliser pour
effectivement faire que l'action de
l'état des différentes collectivités et
l'argent privé puisse se concentrer
massivement sur un certain nombre de
sujets d'importance
donc je disais tout à l'heure
notre travail a commencé par essayer de
travailler sur l'anticipation des
besoins de la france mais aussi du reste
du monde parce que si on veut vendre si
on va virer le commerce extérieur il
faut vendre nos produits et nos services
reste du monde
anticiper les besoins de nos sociétés en
2030 et réfléchir aussi vous êtes ou
actuels de de ce que nous sommes nous
sommes partis effectivement très
rapidement du fait que pour être un
excellent danseur il valait mieux quand
même en général avant une bonne
formation de danse pour devenir un
cuisinier génial
il valait mieux quand même avoir une
formation en cuisine donc on se dit que
la france
le 2030 doit pouvoir s'asseoir s'appuyer
sur les grands à tous qu'elle a d'ores
et déjà aujourd'hui les grandes forces
qui sont les siennes
alors nous étions en train de travailler
dans des délais très contraint puisqu'on
nous avait demandé un premier rapport
avant le 14 juillet nous avons réussi à
desserrer la contrainte est notre
premier rapport est attendu pour le 9
septembre alors certainement faire un
mois d'août moins estivales que nous
l'aurions attendu au espérer mais je
pense que c'est c'est une fort bonne
décision je crois que l'ampleur du sujet
l'importance du sujet fait qu'on a
besoin effectivement de d'un petit peu
de temps alors voudrais souligner que
cet exercice a été fait de manière
diverse dans un certain nombre de grands
pays du monde déjà les états unis où un
énorme travail sur l'innovation est fait
avec une commission innovation avec
aussi la sélection d'un certain nombre
de profils avec un appel d'offres
mondial pour trouver des innovateurs et
les maîtres au sein de l'administration
américaine particulier il ya quatre
personnes qui ont été choisis pour
travailler à la maison blanche
uniquement pour savoir pour impulser des
innovations et des fenêtres des
transformations internes donc cet
exercice s'appelle le comité jason aux
états unis ça existait donc je dis aussi
dans d'autres pays corée chine etc
le comité jason aux états unis existe de
manière permanente
ça sera aussi une interrogation
française faut-il créer une structure
permanente ou non dans ce domaine
on nous a demandés dans l'admission un
travail de long terme donc ceci est
entre les deux alors pour construire la
réflexion nous avons aujourd'hui
organisée de très nombreuses auditions
nous continuerons ces auditions
on nous dit on des gens très différents
bien sûr des prospectivistes des pme des
jeunes des patrons de grands groupes des
patrons d'organismes de recherche des
syndicalistes le medef etc
alors les débats de la commission sont
parfaitement transparent je crois qu'il
est important de le souligner et nous
nous sommes organisés pour mettre en
ligne l'ensemble des auditions alors
toute audition se passe en deux temps la
partie je dirais de présentation de la
personne qui est avec nous qui est mis
en ligne une partie de questions
réponses s'ils le souhaitent
et puis les questions réponses avec la
commission or or enregistrements
l'expérience montrant que beaucoup
veulent dire des choses nous dire des
choses sans souhaiter qu'il soit
forcément me mise sur le net
nous avons également demandé parce que
nous ne pouvons pas auditionner tout le
monde nous avons demandé des
contributions écrites aux différents
acteurs économiques grandes entreprises
pme des différents éléments de recherche
d administration sectorielle et nous
avons beaucoup de retours
ils sont riches ils sont nombreux et ils
sont en cours d'analysé par la
commission alors nous nous sommes dans
nos délais contraints de démarrage nous
sommes aussi ouverts à des regards
étrangers pour savoir à la fois en
auditions des personnes qui ont un
parcours à l'étranger mais aussi en
consultant nos ambassadeurs pour qu'il
nous fasse un état des lieux de ce que
font en termes stratégiques sur le moyen
long terme les différents pays dans le
monde et nous avons ramené alors des
réponses qui sont pas toutes totalement
homogène en termes de précision
donc nous essayons de l'est
2les égaliser aujourd'hui mais je dois
dire que nous ramenons des informations
extrêmement intéressante sur la façon
dont les grands pays s'organisent
aujourd'hui dans ce domaine de
l'innovation et dans les choix
stratégiques qu'il faut pour 2025 ou
2030 alors nous en sommes encore dans la
phase intermédiaire
je ne peux pas aujourd'hui vous faire un
exposé sur notre futur rapport mais je
peux vous dire d'ores et déjà que le
produit de sortie de la commission le
premier produit de sortie sera des
ambitions clairement identifiés sur
lequel ses membres souhaitent miser
car à la fois créateur d'emplois
d'export et ayant quelque part une
dimension un peu géopolitique c'est à
dire des dimensions où la france sera où
la france ne sera pas avec toutes les
conséquences que cela pourra avoir sur
le long terme je peux dire également que
tous les secteurs ne seront pas
représentés on nous demande d'en retenir
5 6 au maximum
on ne va pas pouvoir effectivement
contenter tout le monde
tous les besoins n'auront donc pas de
réponse vis-à-vis de la commission que
je préside
nous sommes arrivés aussi est la
conclusion claire que la concurrence en
terme d'innovation est aujourd'hui
exacerbée et qu'il faut pas seulement
être beau pour être présent demain sur
le marché mais il faut être le meilleur
et le plus tôt possible sur le marché
time to market je m'excuse de parler
anglais mais être prêt au bon moment sur
le marché est parfois encore plus
important que d'avoir le meilleur
produit
personne ne peut être le meilleur en
tout est cependant à rien n'interdit à
la france de voir naître
l'apple ii demain on va la pelle
d'aujourd'hui l'apple ii demain donc je
pense qu'il faut et ça c'est aussi une
des missions qu'on se fixe dans notre
commission il faut essayer de retrouver
la confiance
monsieur le président paul disais tout à
l'heure la confiance en notre potentiel
en notre audace
la france a vu émerger car matt son
coeur artificiel aldebaran ses projets
de robots ces grands groupes sont aussi
à l'origine d'un grand nombre
d'innovations au réel potentiel
nous devons je pense aussi envoyer un
message fort
tous les gens qui ont envie d'innover
peuvent le faire en france et non pas
comme parfois on l'entend on ne peut
réussir qu'en partant ça aussi c'est un
élément clé et ça veut dire que nous
parlerons aussi sans aucun doute de
l'écosystème dans lequel se développe et
doit se développer l'innovation
alors nous acceptons aussi le risque de
déplaire parce que quand on qui dit
choix implique des déçus des
mécontentements
il y aura des désaccords forcément il y
aura aussi des oppositions à l'idée d'un
état stratège qui investit de manière
ciblée de manière forte
moi je crois que il faut aujourd'hui
savoir prendre des risques et qu'à force
de ne pas oser
ben j'ai découvert ça dans cette
commission je pensais pas que la
situation était aussi grave
la france est actuellement le troisième
pays européen en partant de la fin des
vingt-sept en termes de valeur ajoutée
de l'industrie par rapport au produit
intérieur brut
nous avons un énorme travail collectif à
faire alors on nous a attribué 150
millions d'euros lusage des 150 millions
d'euros n'est bien sûr pas une limite
l'idée d'avoir une stratégie de joie qui
doit insuffler bien plus loin l'action
des pouvoirs publics avec bien sûr un
élément qui me paraît et qui paraît la
commission allait de soi c'est à dire
que dans une situation budgétaire
contrainte il faut concentrer les
efforts il ne faut pas se tromper
d'efforts nous sommes convaincus que
nous avons des atouts importants pour la
réindustrialisation
il ressort de toutes nos auditions
une excellence scientifique française
qui n'est plus à démontrer
des ingénieurs français extrêmement rare
recherché de par leur monde de par le
monde pour leur agilité leur créativité
mais je crois qu'il nous manque
effectivement aujourd'hui cette
confiance ses choix cette envie cette
vista et on va essayer effectivement
modestement d'apporter notre tribu à ce
sujet alors soutenir l'innovation seul
je pense ne suffit pas c'est un tout
qu'il faut construire
la commission va donc apporter des
propositions sur les actions à mettre en
oeuvre pour accélérer l'établissement
d'un écosystème favorable à l'innovation
avec des propositions thématiques en
lien avec les choix de la commission et
des propositions qui seront aussi
généralistes nous avons aujourd'hui et
je crois que c'est très important
aussi dès à présent un des poids
natation de la commission qui est toute
la problématique réglementaire je crois
que nous parlions tout à l'heure des
années 70 nous avons eu pendant très
longtemps un système réglementaire
qu'ils étaient construits de manière
parallèle au développement industriel
et dans un certain nombre de cas pour
soutenir à travers des normes à travers
des standards pour soutenir notre
industrie nous avons aujourd'hui des
systèmes qui sont redevenues je dirais
très peu connectés l'un avec l'autre et
toutes les auditions font valoir le
poids des contraintes réglementaires
aujourd'hui sur notre système industriel
mais de manière plus générale sur notre
économie et plus grave encore sur
l'innovation parce que qui dit
innovation dit effectivement quelque
chose qui n'était pas prévu et donc qui
se heurte dans bon nombre de cas à
l'existence des règles en place
enfin nous sommes
nous sommes aujourd'hui tout à fait
convaincu qu'il ya beaucoup à apprendre
je lisais en commençant de ce qui se
fait ailleurs
nous sommes donc en analyse de des
grands plans stratégiques de des
différents pays est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs c'est qui les uns et des
autres publie assez facilement lors il
publie parce qu'ils ont des auditions
aussi parce que le dise les choses
explicitement je crois qu'on ne fait pas
assez attention et que dans la grande
stratégie qu'il faut qu'on mette en
place il ya effectivement une dimension
qui est géostratégique et qui et comment
nous allons jouer collectivement ce jeu
comment les autres le joue-t-il et
comment on va pouvoir trouver notre
meilleure place voilà très rapidement
messieurs les présidents ce que je
voulais vous dire en introduction et
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure moi
je suis non seulement prête à répondre à
toutes vos questions avec l'aide
d'aurélie fait tôt en particulier mais
aussi d'écouter toutes vos suggestions
vos propositions
alors peut-être un mot sur les choix que
nous allons faire ça fait partie des
problématiques complexes que nous avons
d'abord nous ne voulons pas du tout nous
restreindre uniquement à des
technologies
nous pensons que les innovations d'usagé
sont particulièrement importantes les
prospectivistes nous disent 2030
ce sera de plus en plus une société où
on voudra consommer mieux peut-être
consommer moins
et donc tout n'est pas technologique
d'ailleurs quand on regarde 1 télé anne
iphone c'est c'est un objet beau c'est
un objet qui a un peu de technologie
certes mais c'est surtout un objet qui a
révolutionné le rapport avec l'autre là
la personne et les usages donc tout ce
qui est bien d' usage nous paraît
effectivement un élément tout à fait
considérable deuxième élément trouver le
bon degré de pixels
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour dire que la santé va être un sujet
absolument croissant dans les décennies
à venir que l'allongement de la durée de
vie
des personnes est un élément clé place à
la silver economy
certes sortes de noms la dépendance bon
nous nous sommes convaincus que nous ne
pouvons pas rester dans un grand degré
de généralité donc veut pas dire la
santé comme réponse
on va pas non plus dire uniquement au
sein de la santé je sais pas par exemple
la médecine régénérative en plus précis
quelque chose d'absolument
extraordinaire le fait de pouvoir voir
des droits à repousser ou des organes
repousser quand ils ont été lésés c'est
quand même un tout petit peu spécifique
donc il nous faut trouver aussi le bon
degré de pixels qui soit réellement
effectivement stratégique qui soit pas
trop large et pas trop étroit non plus
donc c'est tout le travail que nous
sommes en train de faire et je dois
pouvoir dire que 120 personnes les
fonctions de manière de fonctionner de
manière extrêmement démocratique nous
constatons une vraie convergence sur un
certain nombre de sujets et avec des
orientations
je dirais de plus en plus clair donc je
crois qu'on va réussir pour le 9
septembre un rendre à rendre une copie
voilà silva vient de se donner un bol
merci tout d'abord je vous remercie
madame d'avoir accepté d'être auditionné
devant deux commissions
on vous connaissez vos talents terme de
manager dans une entreprise qu'on
connaissait bien
je regarde les gens du côté de de mâcon
et cetera n'est ce pas le groupe areva
la question que je vais vous poser
indépendamment du fait que l'existence
ou la création même de votre commission
dénote une volonté d'un état stratège
capable de faire de la prospective et en
particulier de prendre des décisions
dans le domaine de l'innovation vous
l'avez évoqué ce ne sont pas des choix
facile et en tous les cas délicats ce
sans doute il reste que comme vous
l'avez évoqué madame je suis persuadé
que l'enjeu principal dans les 15 ou 20
ans on aura deux enjeux importants sans
doute à de nourrir l'humanité le
deuxième c'est le domaine que je
qualifierais debiotech pris au sens
large qui inclut à la fois la santé mais
qui est bien plus large que ça c'est
sans doute l'hybridation entre le
domaine strictement de biologie
moléculaire et de traitement du signal
autrement dit du des domaines qu'on
appelle t é sé mépris au sens traitement
du signal réellement couplée avec la
biologie moléculaire et les nano
matériaux qu'on peut utiliser d'ailleurs
en médecine et en santé j'ai vu une rate
ça qui en avait coupé la colonne
vertébrale et qui rend marchait avec
denanot connexion tu persuadé que
vis-à-vis de la vieillissement de la
population dans notre europe
il ya des choses énormes à faire des
progrès non vous n'êtes les nanos et le
progrès médical mais je dis
biotechnologies me sens là parce que
s'il ya plein de chant là dedans mais je
me demande sans que vous ne donniez
évidemment
la substance de votre rapport prévu donc
pour le mois de septembre si j'ai bien
compris repousser les critères que vous
avez déjà en tête peut-être pour
sélectionner
autrement dit quelle est la grille où le
tamis que vous allez mettre pour arriver
à définir les cinq ou six projets
industriels innovants
donc ce que c'est les domaines bien sûr
de l'innovation dans lequel la
prospective bon ou donnera des
éclairages mais quels sont les autres
critères la taille éventuellement
l'emploi l'export vous l'avez évoqué
pour situer la france dans le domaine de
l'innovation
j'ai bien compris qu'il ya vous aviez
150 millions pour accompagner ces cinq
ou six projets mais je voudrais savoir
quelle est l'articulation de votre
commission avec le commissariat général
à la stratégie la prospective que nous
appelions notre génération
le plan ça ne rajeunit pas remet ainsi
qu'avec le commissariat général à
l'investissement
voilà les quelques questions que je vous
le souhaitez vous faisait en vous
remerciant d'être présente ce m merci
alors madame odette herviaux monsieur le
président ce n'est pas tant une question
peut-être qu'une qu'une intervention en
faveur 2 vous avez dit madame que vous
auriez
à coeur de promouvoir dans vos choix
tout ce qui sera liée au transport
l'ouverture au monde ayant un rôle
stratégique et bien sûr je penserai
n'étonnera personne d'un de mes
collègues de dire que moi je veux unités
pour que la mère se prises notamment les
transports maritimes et tout ce qui
touche à cela soit pris en compte
ça peut paraître tout à fait charles le
contrat ne contredira pas ça peut
paraître un peu anecdotique mais je
crois que il faut qu'on prenne
conscience dans notre pays que tout ce
qui vient pour l'avenir
par exemple les énergies renouvelables
maritime en mer ce sont bien sûr des
savoir faire des compétitions sur les
grands champs de l'énergie mais c'est
d'abord et avant tout un domaine
maritime et la mer étant un élément
hostile
il y aura besoin de savoir faire de le
marin de navires et je crois que nos
armateurs devront avoir la possibilité
de d'être soutenus ce secteur-là le
transport international sera basée alors
il ya des secteurs dans lesquels on
n'est absolument pas compétitif je pense
au vraquier choses comme ça mais on est
quand même très compétitif dans les cas
blier dans toutes ces choses là qui sont
liées à ces futurs énergies marines
renouvelables et je crois que là on ne
peut envisager l'avenir si on n'a pas
cette volonté de faire du domaine
maritime et de la mer en général un
secteur porteur un secteur en
développement
alors bien sûr c'est tu peux rire
monsieur le président
non mais je crois que c'est vraiment
très important et je
on sait très bien que l'avenir de notre
secteur maritime on a des alors il ya
des atouts là aussi des avantages des
inconvénients on dit que nos marins
coûte cher mais ils ont la réputation
d'être très bon voilà il faut qu'on
arrive à avoir cette cette force de
développement si on veut aller vers
d'autres
secteurs en pointe si énorme
la parole est donnée à monsieur rémy
pointereau oui madame la présidente
voici vous permettez je voudrais évoquer
l'énergie un domaine que vous connaissez
bien et qui est un troisième en jeu par
rapport à ce que disait daniel route
pour les trois années qui viennent les
17 années qui viennent par rapport à
l'énergie fossile bon comment vous voyez
les choses est ce que on peut trouver de
nouveaux procédés pour de nouveaux
gisements et qu'elle dans quels domaines
les gaz de schiste est ce que nous
allons trouver des des procédés nouveaux
pour essayer de d'extraire cette énergie
qui est par exemple aux états unis qui
leur permet d'être de plus en plus
indépendants de du pétrole l'énergie
aussi stocks le stockage de l'énergie
par rapport à l'électricité
est ce qu'on peut trouver des moyens
fiable dans les années qui viennent pour
essayer de stocker l'énergie
et puis vous évoquez également le éviter
de taper sur le
sur la gouvernance
avec l'alternance y ait des changements
d'orientation et c'est vrai que ça pose
problème quand même notamment dans le
domaine de la fiscalité de l'énergie
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'il faudrait figé pour
essayer qu'on ait une linéaire dans le
domaine de l'énergie pour pâques on
zappe on a vu avec le photovoltaïque est
ce que ça a pu donner l'éolien on voit
bien aussi qu'il ya des il y aura des
freins aussi à un moment donné notamment
sous domaines l'environnement
donc voilà je voulais vous poser cette
question sur l'énergie qui me paraît
quand même un enjeu est essentielle en
plus de nourrir l'humanité et des
biotech je pense qu'il ya ce domaine là
qui me paraît vraiment important merci
monsieur charles revêt oui la présidente
une infection et d'autres questions
rapides la première réflexion c'est bien
sûr faire de la prospective essayer de
réfléchir et vous l'avez dit 2030 c'est
dans dix sept ans donc c'est demain
soyons clairs et donc je crois que si
avait pas eu ces thèmes réflexion en
amont avec tout ce qui s'est construit
qui place la france dans beaucoup de
domaines de pointe en position là sur le
haut du tableau et non pas les derniers
comme nous sommes dans d'autres domaines
alors même et mes questions c'est vrai
que dans le suivi de ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure notamment peur par
d'interviews on a beaucoup travaillé
ensemble tous les prix continuent de
travailler ensemble sur les problèmes
maritimes
quel est votre périmètre de réflexion je
veux dire par là est ce que ça se limite
à faire des propositions et je vous
indique que vous n y ont mis un peu
l'eau à la bouche tout à l'heure de
manière très habile
le président de commission des affaires
économiques que vous a dit mais vous
n'allez pas nous dire ce que vous nous
avez dit qu'il y avait déjà 5 qui sait
émerger peut-être que pour vous y est
vous pourriez peut-être qu'elle ne nous
laissait entendre quelles sont les
pistes sur lesquelles vous orienter re
priorité mais ça c'est un peu la
bouteille n'engendraient veut dire quel
est le périmètre de réflexion
justement est-ce que ça vraiment le
domaine maritime
par ailleurs vous êtes un exemple est ce
que vous êtes uniquement dans la
technologie où tout ce qui est similaire
écologie ou si les problèmes
organisationnels sont aussi dans votre
domaine d'intervention c'est la suite
logique de la réflexion sur une
technologie deuxième point avec
l'émergence des nouveaux pays comme la
chine comme l'inde comme le brésil et il
y en aura d'autres demain à côté des
états unis
c'est clair que la france avec ses 66
millions d'habitants et son périmètre
même s'il est très très grand les chants
du monde n'a pas la dimension financière
comparé à vos autres il faut quand même
de l'argent et on le voit d'ailleurs
dans un domaine particulier qui est
celui de la défense puisqu'on a livre
blanc et qu'on voit bien qu'on est
obligé de réduire beaucoup de choses
parce qu'on n'est pas capable
d'entretenir une dimension alors est ce
que l'europe dans certains domaines
peut être un moyen est ce qu'on peut
mieux conjuguer nos efforts avec
l'europe
et le troisième point mais tout se lit
le pays qui est le plus proche
fall les pays qui soit plus proche de
nous c'est l'afrique avec ses bientôt de
mairie en 2050 on nous dit qu'il y aura
deux milliards d'habitants il y en a 1
milliard de tweets
ça veut dire un marché potentiel sur
lequel on n'est pas ou très peu tout de
suite alors que la fonte et a les
meilleurs atouts pour y est
la chine y est les autres aussi et on
est en train d'abandonner ce qui
pourrait être un élément moteur de notre
développement
est-ce que aussi vous travaillez sur ces
domaines
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente à la france a un certain
nombre de champions européens et même
mondiaux dans différents secteurs
le nucléaire vous savez mieux que
quiconque l'énergie les transports les
télécommunications la pharmacie
notamment est donc conforté ce secteur
constitue un enjeu majeur
mais cela ne suffit pas en effet une des
difficultés principales de l'économie
française peut être la difficulté
principale tient au fait que les pme en
france sont très nombreuses mais de
taille bien inférieure en particulier
aux pme en allemagne et elle est souvent
faute d'une taille suffisante de moyens
financiers suffisants
elles ne peuvent pas consacrer beaucoup
d'argent à la recherche développement ce
qui fait que l ont beaucoup de mal
globalement à exporter et c'est une des
cause vraisemblablement de limoux
vésicale notre balance extérieure donc
comment avec les 150 millions d'euros
issus du programme d'investissements
d'avenir qui sont gérés par la banque
publique d'investissement pourront-elles
être pourrons nous fait ch et finalement
des soutiens financiers veut dire est
sur un secteur qui est aussi diversifiée
donc ça pose à mon sens la question bien
sûr d'effectuer les bons choix mais
aussi la question de la complémentarité
entre la politique publique
d'investissement et le financement par
le secteur privé lui même cette bonne
complémentarité à mon avis qu'on peut
trouver dans notre état européen dans le
monde est absolument essentiel il faut
qu'on ait un bon relais entre la
politique finalement public de
l'innovation et par ailleurs le soutien
apporté par le secteur financier
bien sûr lui-même par le secteur
industriel privé lui-même
comment voyez vous cette complémentarité
qui me paraît absolument nécessaire
merci monsieur robert navarro cible sur
le président a aussi madame anne
lauvergeon
moi je suis très heureux de vous écouter
parce que j'ai confiance en vos
compétences et aux choix qui a été fait
par le gouvernement vous concernant
maintenant les compliments étant passé
je voudrais
je voudrais vous m je voudrais vous
mettre un gardien sur les choix
importants que vous avez aimé déjà moi
au niveau financier ce qui ne sont pas
au niveau
je trouve qu'il devait avoir comme ça a
été dit une corrélation européenne parce
qu'aucun des secteurs concernés n'a
qu'une vocation hexagonal aucun des
grands secteurs qui peuvent être
porteurs de richesses développement pour
notre pays parce que la finalité de
notre action c'est cela c'est pas la
recherche pour la recherche c'est pas
pour faire plaisir à certains
scientifiques d'aller explorer des
milieux qui peuvent être porteurs de
richesses dans les logiciels ou de nom
pour le moment on a un pays qui est en
jachère un qui est un logiciel sur
l'économie verte atrophique dont oui moi
je trouve que les financements que vous
avez ne sont pas assez haut niveau mais
on se répète trop souvent ils en
auraient dû mettre cela en corrélation
avec l'europe et le choix des secteurs
que vous allez identifier celles au
dessus ou josé vous éveillez sont très
très importants
ne vous trompez pas de secteur parce
qu'on nous a trop souvent engagés sur
des secteurs qui ont été les voies sans
issue je voudrais pas que ça se remette
en place une autre alerte que je
voudrais vous signaler structures et des
grains de groupes qui vont être
producteur de richesse pour notre pays
et d'emploi oui ce serait des grands
groupes qui après vont aller s'installer
à l'extérieur faire des bénéfices
colossaux supprimer des emplois comme le
fait sanofi chez nous après avoir
récupéré un maximum d'audience publique
ça ça ne m'intéresse pas que les groupes
fassent de faire des affaires les
actionnaires c'est pas intéressant faut
que la richesse lamotte réflexion reste
sur le territoire et sera productrice
d'emploi pour nos concitoyens
là vous aurez rendu service à notre
république qui en a grand besoin
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur
marcel deneux sur le président madame
mes premiers mots c'est quand même deux
me féliciter de l'endroit où vous êtes
venu madame lauvergeon et de remercier
les gens qui vous ont nommé pour une
fois on a peut-être les bonnes personnes
au bon endroit alors on va voir ce que
ça donne mais moi je fais confiance je
suis heureux que vous soyez sur ce point
m'ayant dit tout ce que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses ce que vous avez dit
moi je partage à peu près tout alors il
ya des problèmes de court terme et des
problèmes à plus long terme c'est
difficile sur le long terme moi je pense
qu'il ya deux problèmes essentiels tous
les hôtes en découvrons c'est de savoir
nourrir le monde et sa subsistance à
moyen terme et à 50 ans et puis l'autre
à faire c'est de lutter contre
l'accroissement des gaz à effet de serre
avec toutes les déclinaisons économique
et sociale alors à point que je voudrais
retenir je veux pas être con me prouver
mais essentielle et c'est presque le
seul c'est la formation des hommes et
des femmes bien sûr remettre la france
d'aplomb matière d'enseignement à
l'école primaire quand le voit d'autres
niveaux
la génération qui se prépare à et écoles
primaires aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
très très bien
par rapport à l'échelle du monde et puis
vous qui n'êtes pas tout à fait un
produit des grandes universités
regardez comment on peut donner de
l'efficacité à d'autres échelons c'est à
dire nos universités par rapport aux
universités internationales hôte la
france n'est pas les mieux placés
est-ce qu'on peut coordonner tout ça
pour faire clair il faut préparer les
hommes à être au bon niveau dans trente
ans et ça commence sans doute par école
primaire
enfin un aspect sectorielle parce que je
le vis actuellement nous avons décidé
l'office parlementaire des choix
scientifiques hier de faire un rapport
qui est intitulé vous donne le titre
nous avons changé hier soir eu les
freins réglementaires à l'innovation en
matière de l'efficacité énergétique des
bâtiments
parce que nous considérons que c'est le
secteur essentiel est qu'il ya
suffisamment de blocage pour qu'on s'en
occupe mais le président de l'office qui
erreur aurait dit mieux que moi mais je
veux vous donner une nouvelle je pense
qu'on sera amené à cog à bord
quelque part avec vos prérogatives merci
monsieur hervé maurey merci messieurs
les présidents mais à la présidence j'ai
été très très intéressé par tout ce que
vous avez dit et j'avoue que je suis
parfois et même plus que parfois désole
de voir qu'en fait depuis un certain
nombre d'années on a plus d'êta stratège
on a parfois même le sentiment que les
gouvernements successifs soutienne
davantage des industries dépassé que des
industries d'avenir
je m'intéresse un peu aux questions du
numérique on a par exemple en france une
industrie de la fibre optique qui est à
mon sens pas suffisamment soutenu et qui
un jour disparaîtra donc l'idée de
d'avoir un état stratège qui est capable
comme vous l'avez rappelé comme on l'a
fait dans le passé de 2,2 d'identifier
des secteurs porteurs pour faire en
sorte de faire des deux vraies
locomotives me paraît tout à fait
essentiel et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde un petit peu vu de
l'extérieur c'est toujours là que l'on
voit mieux les choses
la situation industrielle de la france
de faire plaisir à un raymond vall on a
le sentiment qu'à par l'industrie
aéronautique
on est plutôt en recul sur les domaines
même où on était il n'ya pas si
longtemps les les plus forts alors il
faut vous l'avez dit faire des choix et
c'est tout à fait normal et c'est même
nécessaire que les choix que vous ferez
ne plaisent pas à tout le monde peut s'y
plaisait à tout le monde ça veut dire
qu'ils sont pas assez assez hiérarchiser
assez ciblées
maintenant la question que je me pose et
que je vous pose c'est comment on fait
comment on fera pour que ce rapport que
vous allez rendre et qui sera
certainement très intéressants et très
pertinent ne reste pas un rapport c'est
à dire comment on fait pour que les
préconisations que vous ferez dont je
veux bien croire qu'elles seront tout à
fait pertinentes soient suivies d'effets
et vous avez vous même identifié un
certain nombre d'obstacles
il ya des obstacles très important non
seulement le fait d'être le meilleur sur
certains secteurs qui en soi n'est pas
facile mais au delà il ya
l'environnement réglementaire et fiscal
dont vous et souligner qu'aujourd'hui il
n'était pas du tout favorable à
l'entreprise l innovation alors comment
on peut dans une homme
un pays où il ya des difficultés
financières et budgétaires où il ya
aussi des obstacles culturels
comment on fait pour revenir sur un
environnement juridique et fiscal qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas favorable et
comment on fait je crois que c'est
encore plus difficile pour redonner
confiance à nos concitoyens et notamment
aux jeunes parce que vous l'avez dit là
aussi aujourd'hui un jeune il penser de
plus en plus que pour réussir il faut
partir alors comment comment on fait
pour redonner le goût d'entreprendre et
le goût de réussir
j'avoue que je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
dans la politique mise en place des
mesures qui aillent dans ce sens là donc
je serais très heureux d'entendre vos
réflexions sur le solde
merci monsieur roland courteau oui
j'allais repenser la question de
monsieur moore et comment ferez vous
pour que se répondent ne reste pas un
rapport mais je voudrais je voudrais
également revenir sur notre domaine où
nous sommes déjà leader vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure
comment faire une politique de long
terme nous sommes déjà leader dans ce
domaine là il faudrait le rester et ce
d'autant qu'il génère quelque chose
comme 330 mille emplois directs et 1
million d'emplois indirects
c'est l'aviation civile il s'agit là
d'un roi du résultat d'une politique de
long terme nous savons qu'à l'horizon
2030 le nombre de passagers dans le
monde va doubler nous serons très
certainement autour de 5,7 milliards de
passagers nous savons que les avions
devront être plus économes en carburant
nous savons que devront émettre moins de
gaz à effet de serre bref des ruptures
technologiques ont déjà eu lieu avec la
rive carbone d'ailleurs au passage
rappelons que si on allège la masse d'un
avion d'une tonne sur la durée de vie de
l'avion
c'est 6000 tonnes de carburant
économisées c'est dire l'importance
d'alléger là la masse des avions bref il
faut s'attendre d'importantes ruptures
technologiques sur l'architecturé des
avions sur les moteurs est également
sous le biokérosène de troisième
génération ou là on n'avance pas
tellement vite
bref il semble que nous ayons enfin que
la courbe de progrès dans l'aviation
civile soit asymptotique ce qui implique
vraiment des ruptures technologiques
d'importance
or ce signal sur ce point que les amis
les américains mettent le paquet en
matière de recherche
je signale que les chinois en font
autant les de façon très lascive et puis
je constate que depuis 2000 heureuse le
budget de la france consacré à l'onera
est passé de 140 millions à 60 millions
d'euros
l'onera je le rappelle c'est la
charnière entre la recherche académique
et le développement de technologique de
base
je pourrais également évoqué le problème
de financement du corac qui travaille
sur les nouvelles configurations
d'aéronefs et sur les ruptures
technologiques bref ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que voilà un secteur nous
sommes leader actuellement l'attention
de ne pas être relégués après les états
unis et après la chine parce que les
crédits à la recherche serait nettement
en recul et monsieur jean jacques
mirassou oui moi je vais vous
interpellez madame présidente une
question qui taraude les esprits
peut-être parfois l'ayant peut tout à
fait mais diagnostic que mes collègues
s'agissant de la vocation de votre
mission et vous avez tous leurs évoqué
le fait que être utile à la société tout
en générant des emplois et je crois que
là on est véritablement dans ce qui
garantit ce qu'on appelle à l'intérêt
général et quand même temps l'état
stratège ne peut pas faire l'impasse sur
ses responsabilités donc la question que
je me pose c'est de savoir quelle va
être la retire
relation entre ce que va révéler le
travail de votre commission aux missions
et en mettant les ministères qui sont
les plus concernés je veux parler des
suivis redressement productif et de
celui également de la recherche
alors j'imagine qu'on vous a assigné le
forme de liberté d'action et de pensée
mais la difficulté de réussir de style
va consister ensuite à rentrer dans les
travaux pratiques
faute de quoi vous auriez amener une
dimension intellectuelle avancée mais
qui serait pas tellement reproductive
donc ça ça m'intéresse prodigieusement
de savoir comment vous voyez cet avenir
est en même temps je reviens à ce qui a
été évoqué en tant que toulousains n'ont
pas l'aéronautique
même si au passage quand on dit états
responsabilités sur le plan de la
stratégie industrielle
je n'arrive pas à me satisfaire du
désengagement de l'état dans les
secteurs clés et quand je dis ça j'ai
fait directement référence à la perte de
l'actif de l'état
ainsi concerne la ds mais c'est pas sûr
ça que je vais m'interroger vous vous
interrogez c'est sûr sur sanofi est un
vaisseau amiral des industries
pharmaceutiques et qui au moment où il
va opérer une formidable mutation ce qui
concerne les rennais un délice en
quelque sorte il va booster pour se
diriger vers des médicaments devenir
plus personnalisé et je rejoins la
préoccupation de la nied raul
paradoxalement on assiste quelque sorte
à la tentation de diminuer la voie de la
voilure en ce qui concerne la r&d au
niveau du personnel avec faut-il le
préciser
une industrie qui concurrence totale
dans le classement au niveau du cac 40
qui bon an mal an dégage entre 5 et 8
milliards de bénéfices
et là on est au coeur de ce que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'est utile et la
société créateurs d'emplois faire
l'impasse sur cette responsabilité-là du
point de vue de ses laboratoires serait
à mon sens une faute énorme parce que
même si son devoir et tournée vers
l'avenir et personne ne peut négliger
cette dimension là il reste quand même à
ce qui concerne les anciennes
médicaments des marchés appelons les
comme ça y compris en france par rapport
des pathologies infectieuses qui ne sont
pas encore maîtrisés
sur le plan des spécialités
pharmaceutiques je parle je veux même
pas parler des pays émergents ou
d'afrique noire donc là il y aura des
choix à faire et le raisonnement un peu
égoïste qui consisterait à dire on se
tourne préférentiellement vers l'avenir
me semble terriblement respectifs par
rapport à la mission qui vous a été
assignée et qui donc pas contre cours
est assignée aux mêmes laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
merci monsieur yannick vaugrenard oui
merci monsieur le président madame
lauvergeon vous le disiez tout à l'heure
finalement 2030 que c'est pas prêt
demain c'est demain et voici 17 ans
j'essayais de m'imaginer qu'elle est
elle une forme de pensée dominante
c'était plutôt que l'économie de marché
allait tout régler et qui avait pas
besoin d'être stratège en quelque sorte
est ce que c'est la magie de votre
présence mais j'ai l'impression que ce
matin tout le monde est d'accord tout
court en politique vous produit sur le
fait qu'il ait de la nécessité d'un état
stratège
donc c'est bien qu'ils essaient
d'avancer là en fonction aussi de la
réalité objective des choses ce qui a
beaucoup évolué durant ces 17 dernières
années et aussi les moyens de
communication individuelle il cet outil
formidable que nous avons tous a été je
trouve extrêmement bien l'image est
développé sur le plan philosophique par
michel serres dans son petit livre
petite poucette on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui ce formidable
dictionnaire permanent permet d'être au
courant tout d'être informé de tout dans
la seconde dans la minute qui suit et du
coup ça transforme complètement
également le domaine de la formation qui
est évoqué par charles de ne tout à
l'heure le domaine de la formation et de
l'enseignement va automatiquement changé
et évolué de par ce simple fait là est
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
dans 10 ou 15 ans est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres moyens de communication qui
permettront de changer aussi une manière
considérable à la fois de relier des
individus entre eux et souvent de
manière très impersonnel finalement il
sent qu'il est le contact et l'humanité
qui est habituellement un premier roman
la deuxième remarque c'est par rapport
au développement de l'énergie
hydrolienne louis gallois l'évoqué
devant nous
à l'occasion d'une dernière audition
c'est un formidable moyen de
développement énergétique parce que
l'énergie des courants ses permanents
c'est pas comme le vent ou d'autres
énergies et du coup est ce que dans ce
domaine particulier notre pays ne
devrait pas investir de manière beaucoup
plus forte parce que nous disposons de
courants importants du fait de sa
situation géographique est ce qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire dans les 17 années
à venir de prévoir un investissement
très fort dans le domaine du
développement de l'énergie hydrolienne
si monsieur jean-jacques lionne merci
monsieur le président votre présence à
une verge ont fait de lui la loi dans le
domaine industriel montrent qu'il y
avait volonté du gouvernement d' de fait
d'une vraie rupture croire et qui est
vraiment nécessaire il
il faut que la france retrouve un destin
industriels c'est son avenir en même
temps que je j'ai eu le plaisir de vous
accueillir à montluçon loire vous ai
visité une entreprise innovante dans le
domaine de l'aéronautique tels des avec
le taxi bottes un qui qui économise
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie pour le
décollage des avions sur les aéroports
donc sur la prouve que vous êtes déjà au
coeur du sujet et je trouve que c'est
vraiment décisif en même temps je vais
parler d'une filière qui n'existe pas à
mes filles qui fonctionne tous les jours
et vous l'avez évoqué en parlant des
contraintes nous sommes élus de terrain
ne connaissons les entreprises petites
moyennes et quelquefois même des
entreprises personnelles et on sait très
bien que meilleurs malheureusement il y
à chaque jour des entreprises qui sont
freinés dans leur production dans leurs
innovations dans leur développement par
des contraintes souvent des contraintes
administratives
de gens qui ne s'imagine pas le dit jean
qui ne s'imagine pas le mal qu'ils font
au développement d'entreprises moi j'en
connais beaucoup et tout le monde ici on
connaît j'ai parce que daniel en
particulier quand on est bien tous ces
bruits industriels et de recherche
voilà elle freine beaucoup de choses
elle freine découragent souvent des
entreprises il décourage
oui le développement l'innovation
moi je voulais savoir comment vous allez
explorer ce dossier alors ce n'est pas
une filière global c'est vrai mais c'est
la filière du quotidien et c'est celle
qui peut être sur le terrain peut
permettre de dégager des forces
nouvelles et je pense que même si la bpi
va être attentif même si tout ce qui a
été mis par le gouvernement en place et
j'y crois va aider à limiter la classe
si je puis dire il n'empêche ce qu'est
il n'empêche qu'elle existe et puis moi
j'aurai quelques mots sur sanofi sanofi
existe aussi dans mon département
je suis aussi d'accord avec toi
jean-jacques ce qui en même temps moi
j'ai travaillé 28 ans dans un abattoir
forme sites pharmaceutiques ce thème
files air qui avaient des laboratoires
très important au monde entier
aujourd'hui à plus de laboratoires
quasiment plus il en disant on supprime
supprimer 1
dans mon département de 180 personnes et
1 5 ans à la place du laboratoire
aujourd'hui qui était ultra innovant il
avait investi 500 millions d'euros en
l'espace de cinq ans précédemment
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
laboratoires
il ya une pelouse en place l'ancien
gouvernement avait fait des promesses
qui n'ont pas été tenues évidemment
puisque non puisque
l'industriel industrielle avait décidé
lundi
l'industriel avait décidé une stratégie
serkin au travail maintenant que sur des
start up
ils rachètent des start up qui développe
elle-même des produits innovants ils les
achètent très cher ils les développe et
on en fait à pleurer après des
blockbusters sur le marché mondial et
j'ai bien peur que hills and sanofi soit
aussi dans cette dimension là alors
peut-être faut-il évidemment dans la
stratégie qui est la vôtre et celle de
l'ue gallois veut garder ses promenades
très près merci monsieur ronan dantec
oui j'ai écouté avec attention mais mes
collègues je crois que je suis d'accord
avec beaucoup de choses que j'ai entendu
précédemment notamment ce paradoxe
français qui est finalement on est resté
un pays très colbertiste donc à une
réflexion souvent franco-française et et
en parallèle plus de stratégie
industrielle donc les deux cumulent et
le monde devient difficile à affronter
donc moi mais mes deux interrogations
par rapport à votre à votre travail qui
est évidemment un travail important
la première mais charles revêt avait
commencé à le dire que robert navarro 6
c'est à dire si on sort de cette
réflexion collective par des
propositions franco française on sera
passé probablement totalement à travers
c'est à dire que ce qu'on attend
aujourd'hui comme stratégie ces
stratégies de structuration des filières
européennes avec un pilotage européen
une gouvernance européenne que nous
sommes par culture et par tradition
absolument pas préparé à ça qu'on aurait
même une tendance naturelle à essayer de
défendre nos anciens secteur et qu on
fait ça depuis trente ans en s'épuisant
à conserver des secteurs qui sont faites
marginalisés à l'échelle européenne ou
mondiale et donc moi ce que j'ai
j'attends un petit peu et vous prêtez
nous en donner quelques indications
aujourd'hui c'est dire voilà aujourd'hui
l'intégration européenne et la
gouvernance européenne des grandes
filières industrielles que nous français
nous proposons je crois que ça c'est le
point clé et canton si l'aéronautique la
différence entre l'aéronautique et nos
secteurs traditionnels comme
l'automobile l'aéronautique c'est bien
une gouvernance européenne
c'est bien des moyens européens qui sont
qui sont mutualisés donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point est un
peu en lien c'est à dire la question qui
nous est posée aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on affronte les conservatismes
français et en termes industriels et
économiques les les conservatismes sont
même assez partagés entre les différents
échiquier politique
nous avons des secteurs que nous
considérons comme des secteurs de pointe
et qui sont des secteurs plutôt
marginalisée au moins à l'échelle
européenne
je sais que je vais être un peu
provocateur mais tout le monde m'attend
là dessus il est clair qu'aujourd'hui à
l'échelle européenne par exemple le
nucléaire est plutôt une industrie
d'appoint si on prend les chiffres doré
lectrique ses 250 milliards
d'investissements dans le renouvelable
l'échelle européenne dans les dix
prochaines années et 16 milliards dans
le nucléaire c'est le rapport d' enquête
parlementaire sénatoriale qui a confirmé
ces chiffres là non c'est les chiffres
de ré lectrique reprenez le rapport d'
enquête sénatoriale
c'est quand même étonnant que on
n'affronte pas les chiffres
donc en tout cas un certain nombre de
réactions de mes collègues prouve qu'on
a toujours du mal à affronter la réalité
du monde européen tel qu'il est et que
donc à partir de là mais ça ça joue
aussi dans d'autres domaines le domaine
de l'automobile et et là dessus un
domaine intéressant je vois qu'on a
toujours autant de mal avec le réel le
dans le domaine de l'automobile
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons une industrie française qui
n'a pas pris non plus
le tournant des grands enjeux
environnementaux et même on pourrait
considérer qu'une part du déclin
industriel français c'est le fait de ne
pas avoir intégré dans les années 80 les
enjeux environnementaux et émergents y
compris par rapport aux allemands et
donc est ce que dans le cadre de votre
mission vous avez aussi capacité à faire
des propositions de sortie de secteurs
qui sont plutôt considérés comme des
secteurs forts de notre patrimoine
industriel mais qui n'ont qui sont des
secteurs de niche qui n'ont pas un
avenir si important que ça et que sortir
en bon ordre
deux secteurs où on a mis beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup d'énergie et où des
gens très brillants se sont investis
depuis très longtemps est une des clés
de l'avenir industriel français et je
crois que c'est aussi sur les
propositions de sortie d'un certain
nombre de secteurs que se jouera
l'avenir industriel français si madame
bernadette bourzai merci monsieur le
président mon intervention va être assez
bref parce que quand on arrive en
dernier presque tout a été dit je
souhaitais en effet parlé de la
formation marcel deneux l'a fait parler
d énergie moi je suis plutôt source
d'énergie renouvelable que nucléaire
donc voilà ça vient également d'être dit
mais pas forcément dans les termes que
j'aurais employés c'est pas grave moi je
souhaiterais reprendre une de vos
observations qui disait va vous disiez
tout à l'heure que il fallait être
attentif aux usages et je pense qu'il y
à des secteurs où les usages vont
devenir extrêmement important en matière
de développement ce temps particulier
tout ce qui concerne la silver economy
les personnes âgées le maintien à
domicile
la médecine la télémédecine et cetera
parce que bon je suis élu du limousin
qui est vous le savez sans doute la
région la plus
vieilles d'europe ça nous donne une
obligation qui est de maintenir à
domicile ou d'accueillir dans des
établissements spécialisés des personnes
de très grandes tâches très grand âge
malgré la radioactivité du limousin dont
vous voyez que ça conserve finalement
plus que ça ne détruit et nous sommes en
train de mettre en place des politiques
de mattia domicile avec la domotique
la firme legrand en particulier étant
spécialisée dans ce secteur je crois
qu'il ya là un usage important qu'il
faut qu'il convient de conforter parce
que c'est nous sommes l'image de
l'europe dans 15 ans et 20 ans c'est à
dire en 2030 et nous avons ce devoir là
de préfigurer en somme
donc voilà une idée du développement des
usages innovants
merci alors dernier interlocuteur c'est
monsieur didier guillaume
merci monsieur le président très heureux
de vous retrouver ce matin madame dans
une autre avec une autre casquette
alors moi je vais très très court
d'autant plus que j'ai horreur
l'impolitesse de devoir partir dans 5
minutes dont plus près pas écouter la
suite
et comme je suis incapable de savoir
quelles sont les clefs les filières
d'avenir industriel de notre pays de
notre planète
ce serait jouer simplement dire 2
conviction que j'ai au fond de moi même
je pense déjà que le fait qu'on reparle
d'état stratège et que l'on se dise mon
sang de bonsoir on n'est pas obligé
d'aller dans déclin et de se casser la
figure comme on le fait c'est depuis des
années c'est quand même quelque chose de
bien après il faudra trouver où aller en
tout cas tous les outils que nous avions
tout à l'heure le prix d'un raul en
parler ont été démontés les uns après
les autres ou ont été se sont épuisés
parce qu'il n'avait plus les moyens de
fonctionner et on s'aperçoit qu'une fine
et aujourd'hui dans cette mondialisation
effrénée
c'est pas le libéralisme qui peut sauver
la planète mais c'est au contraire une
économie planifiée entre guillemets avec
des stratégies et ça aujourd'hui je suis
heureux de constater tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus ça empêche pas connu
de divergences politiques mais tout le
monde est
là dessus le libéralisme va mettre la
planète dans une difficulté immense et
la régulation c'est ce que ce dont nous
parlons ce matin ils sont nous sommes
tous d'accord est une des réponses
peut-être je n'en suis pas sûr moi ya
deux sujets qui me semble important
générateur d'emplois me semble-t-il le
premier on a parlé un grand plan de
fribourg fibre optique on allait parler
de précédents gouvernements
l'actuel en a parlé il ya certes les
tuyaux indispensable la fibre optique
partout les milliards on va le faire
pour tous mais c'est surtout les usages
ont parlé des usages et là tu me
semble-t-il
on a la possibilité de trouver des
niches terrible dans plein de sujets et
moi je vais prendre un exemple dans le
département de la drôme il ya une petite
commune s'appelle l'union si un hôpital
l'hôpital devait être fermée service
radiologie devaient être fermés il a été
maintenu uniquement parce que le conseil
général a tiré deux mille trois cents
kilomètres de fibre optique que la fibre
optique arrive alliance et que désormais
cet hôpital fonctionne parce qu'il est
en lien et depuis un mois maintenant
parce qu'il est en lien avec valence
avec grenoble avec lyon et parce que les
radiologues fondé je prends cet exemple
mais à travers la fibre optique je pense
que nous avons un développement énorme
en terme en termes et les usa en termes
d' usage de d'un autre dans notre pays
et puis le deuxième sujet pour les très
vite issue de l'énergie issue de
l'énergie je reste persuadé que
aujourd'hui on revient ce qui se passe
avec les éoliennes avec la fibre optique
on a des produits qui viennent de
l'extérieur on est plus incapable plus
capable de créer quoi que ce soit de
fond de court soit il ya plus de ya plus
d'entreprises et je pense qu'il faut il
faut y aller là dedans et dans l'énergie
ne doutons pas que ce sera un des
problèmes cruciaux de la planète
on devrait avancer et contrairement à
mon excellent collègue ronan ronan
dantec je continue à penser que dans les
quarante ans qu'ils viennent si nous
étions capables de faire de la recherche
dans tous les domaines de l'énergie me
demandant nucléaire et de caen et de
construire une quarantaine ou une
cinquantaine de centrales nucléaires de
plus petites catégories de plus petite
puissance
il faudrait il faudrait y aller et je
pense à sera indispensable
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui avec la
turquie a mené à en étonne non mais
rigolez pas parce que vous vous ne
l'avez pas fait et quand le précédent
gouvernement précédent gouvernement et
notamment et notamment quand monsieur
borloo a eu l'opportunité de le faire il
ne l'a pas fait donc on est tous en même
dans le même cas dont repensant oui mais
repensons à tout cela non justement
dépendent et on n'en est pas là mais je
dis simplement que dans mes champs non
mais là dessus ça là dessus vous savez
tout le monde a sa croix à porter et
vous l'avez portez vous l'avez pas vous
l'avez porté pendant dix ans et vous
n'avez pas réhausser la filière
nucléaire et je sais pas si ce
gouvernement le fera
je sais simplement je sais simplement
que il y as en termes de recherche
développement dans ce secteur par
rapport à ce qu'est le marché mondial la
possibilité d'avancer encore nous nous
sommes en plein dans la transition
énergétique
nous savons très bien qu'il faudra
réduire la part du nucléaire et nous
sommes tous d'accord et elle se réduira
mathématiquement mais en séance et
obligatoirement que la demande
d'augmentation de d'énergie au monde va
faire qu'on sera obligé en crapaud
masanet de le faire il nous semble c'est
un créneau porteur d'avenir
si alors monsieur pierre hérisson pour
conclure un tel président et bonjour un
anneau version on va se partager mon
intervention avec mon voisin comme ça il
peut intervenir aussi donc moi je vais
parler du goût de l'effort et lui du
goût du risque
donc ce sera plus simple madame
lauvergeon nous nous vivons dans une
société où on est sous péridurale et on
meurt sous palliatifs on a donc quelque
part inconsciemment on est en train de
perdre le goût de l'effort indispensable
à la recherche au développement à la
rentabilité et à toutes ces choses là
donc mac et mon amant mon intervention
sera très courte
comment est ce que l'on fait dans le
domaine de la stratégie pour redonner en
particulier à la nouvelle génération qui
va arriver aux responsabilités le goût
de l'effort par l'incitation à l'efo
quelles incitations à l'effort quel
intérêt à l'effort parce qu'il faut
aussi penser à ces choses là donc il
faut qu'ils aient une récompense quelque
part peut être suffisamment
substantielles et conséquente à
l'adresse de ceux qui réussissent dans
la recherche/développement expira etc
et puis sur dans le domaine de l'énergie
je crois que il faut que nous fassions
attention aussi à la non pas la peau
pour le coup à la perte du goût de
l'effort
mais à aller vers des clichés tout fait
qu'ils ont oublié quelque part une chose
en route et on en a bien la conséquence
ces jours ci c'est que la france qui
permet ces quelques leviers de
compétitivité
ces entreprises ont l'avantagé de
disposer d'un accès à l'énergie
un des moins chers de l'europe et qui
malheureusement même si nous sommes pas
tous d'accord sur le sujet et je pense
que ce levier de compétitivité devons de
garder
parallèlement à ça pour assurer la
transition énergétique
ou bien créez quelque part les recettes
et le chiffre d'affaires et des recettes
qui permettront de le réaliser
donc on est là dans une espèce de
contradiction j'aimerais que vous nous
disiez comment on peut gérer le passage
de l'un à l'autre où la complémentarité
de l'un à l'autre
je vous remercie et donc michel magras
merci monsieur le président c'est vrai
que j'interviens un tout dernier mais
les sujets que je vais évoquer le sujet
a probablement été évoquée par les
collègues mais je souhaite le dire d'une
manière différente
madame la présidente vous nous avez dit
que par le passé là la france a quand
même réussi à gagner un certain nombre
de places au niveau mondial où elle a
été elle est encore parmi les premiers
au monde
il ya sans doute des raisons à cela
aujourd'hui vous nous dites qu'en termes
de valeur ajoutée dans le domaine
industriel
nous sommes passés au troisième rang
mais à partir de la fin au niveau
européen
bon je dis que la mission qui est la
mode qui consiste à regarder l'avenir et
à nous dire dans les secteurs dans
lesquels la france doit se placer elle
est importante fondamentale mais c'est
un aspect de la question
l'autre aspect que moi je souhaite
évoquer c'est que nous savons tous qu
aujourd'hui les français au sens le plus
large du terme
effectivement s'exporte et éprouvent le
besoin
quel que soit le niveau intellectuel
niveau de découverte de recherche
d'aller à l'extérieur la france pratta
ne pratique plus aujourd'hui nécessite
plus les français à prendre des risques
et pratique
comparativement à d'autres territoires
on connaît le rôle des états unis dans
ce domaine il existe en france une peur
de l'échec qui était nul qui est un
frein absolument fondamental pour
l'avenir
sinon si nous ne réussissons pas à
changer cette peur du risque et cette
culture de l'échec de la le droit à la
deuxième chance voire à la troisième
chance la france ne s'en sortira pas et
l'idée aujourd'hui pour nous c'est pas
seulement de savoir dans quels domaines
la france doit l'état doit inciter les
français à aller c'est aussi de savoir
dans quels domaines la france pourra
ramener vers l quelle politique mettre
en place pour que la france ramène à
l'intérieur du territoire des économies
qu'ils vont enrichir à la france et
comment elle sera capable de s'exporter
aussi à l'extérieur
donc c'est un petit peu ça je ne sais
pas si c'est dans les limites de votre
rapport
mais c'est un petit peu ça le sens de ma
question allez vous aborder la question
de que faut-il faire pour inciter les
français aujourd'hui à innover et et à
10 ans à relancer l'économie française
bien merci alors
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
toutes et tous pour ce formidable cette
formidable contribution je dois dire que
vous allez vous nous alimenter et vous
aller alimenter nos travaux de manière
très très forte et je vais essayer de
répondre aussi aux interrogations que
vous m'avez que vous m'avez exprimer
alors d'abord peut-être une question un
petit peu en commun auquel je voudrais
répondre effectivement on va s'adresser
à l'écosystème en général je crois qu'on
ne peut pas parler d'innovation sans
parler alors c'est vrai quelques
systèmes c'est un peu un mot valise
c'est à moi la mode
moi j'ai une façon peut-être plus imagée
de dire les choses on nous demande quel
type de vitamines et d'alimentation il
faut donner à des poissons pour qu'ils
puissent se développer dans un aquarium
je pense que la première réponse c'est
que l'aquarium doit avoir la bonne
lumière avec la bonne eau la bonne
salinité le bon ph pour développer des
poissons c'est indispensable à partir de
l'or pour développer tel ou tel type de
poisson qu'ils vont être capables de
peuples et de se développer ya
effectivement des recettes spécifiques
mais d'abord il faut avoir un bonhomme
d'aquarium avec la bonne eau la bonne
qualité le bon ph la bonne lumière
donc c'est là où l'écosystème est
complètement clé et je crois
qu'effectivement notre écosystème
français aujourd'hui a des points forts
évident je disais tout à l'heure
d'excellents chercheurs à d'excellents
ingénieurs une tradition je dirais qui a
connu les ingénieurs français par
rapport à des ingénieurs d'autres
nationalités
c'est que un ingénieur français en
général est infiniment plus créatif face
à une situation inattendue qu'un
ingénieur d'une autre nationalité
donc nous avons des je dirais des
caractéristiques qui nous pousse vers
l'innovation
en même temps nous avons aussi il faut
bien le dire une fiscalité des
contraintes réglementaires
j'ai bien aimé la formule que vous avez
utilisé qui est on a gardé le
colbertisme du sur le plan réglementaire
mais on a oublié la stratégie
industrielle c'est un petit peu simple
c'est là qu'on a gardé un côté on a on a
perdu l'autre donc
je voudrais saluer également le bon
juste pour terminer le réglementaire le
fiscal le sujet fiscal est considérable
on voit un syndrome aujourd'hui à ses
forces et il ya aujourd'hui énormément
de start up en france donc le le fait
d'oser faire une start-up existe
beaucoup échouent un certain nombre
d'entre elles réussissent grossistes
donc les fonds d'amorçage ça marche
le premier financement ça marche mais
qu'est ce qui se passe après eh ben on
constate que pour beaucoup d'entre eux
est d'ailleurs c'est une courbe à ces
terribles on vend on vend on vend la
technologie on vend l'innovation en
général à une société étrangère qui va
créer des emplois dans son dans son pays
natal je dirais et l'entrepreneur et
bien s'en va et en général ce sont des
serial entrepreneur ils vont allez
entreprendre ailleurs pour des raisons
fiscales pour ça c'est un énorme sujet
parce que je crois que d'abord il faut
garder ces gens qui ont cette espèce de
2 et en même temps il faut s'interroger
de savoir pourquoi ils ne font pas
grandir leur entreprise pourquoi ils les
vendent parce que c'est trop compliqué
parce que ils ont des preuves de
financement parce que ça c'est un vrai
sujet nous ne voyons pas croître les
entreprises comme nous le voyons aux
états unis par exemple
alors c'est vrai qu'aux états unis vous
avez un énorme marché immédiatement
unifiée avait un système européen
beaucoup plus complexes vous avez
effectivement les le système normatif
français en tout cas ça me paraît une
question commune sur écosystèmes
qu'effectivement nous allons adresser
alors je deuxième réponse peut-être un
petit peu en verve venir à chacune de
vos de vos interrogations mais peut-être
un facteur commun
on s'aperçoit que de plus en plus ce qui
va être facteur d'innovation et de
richesse c'est l'intersection de ce qui
était jusqu'à présent séparés vous
citiez tout ce qui est
biologie et le biologique et les
nanotechnologies
on pourrait citer beaucoup d'autres
exemples le big data avec la finance
donc l'interception d'éléments qui n'ont
jamais parlé entre eux va être
extraordinairement créatif or on
s'aperçoit et nous avons auditionné un
certain nombre de jeunes gens sortant du
système éducatif français
c'était aussi une question qui revenait
des gens qui ont réussi entre guillemets
le système éducatif français qui sortent
des universités qui sortent des grandes
écoles ils nous disent tous écoutez nous
on a tous envie de faire des start up
on a tous envie donc il ya un esprit
entrepreneurial
néanmoins nous ne connaissons que des ne
connaissons que des gens qui ont été
dans les mêmes écoles ou les mêmes
universités que nous dans les mêmes
spécialités l'ain où effectivement vous
êtes om haïti aux états unis
vous êtes sur des campus où il ya toutes
les spécialités ensemble nous nous
sommes dans un système de division deux
silos où chacun est spécialisé donc un
polytechnicien battre avec un
polytechnicien un spécialiste du droit
alors qu'on aurait besoin d'une
hybridation lancer des nouveaux usages
lancer les nouveaux produits ça suppose
d'avoir des gens du design par exemple
faire de beaux objets et complètement
clé faire un beau site faire quelque
chose d'attractif en termes de horse à
quelqu'un qui vient du monde du design à
une chance très faible d'aller
rencontrer un ingénieur versus un
commerçant donc comment est-ce qu'on
organise de manière beaucoup plus
systématique ces choses là alors à titre
personnel je suis très impliquée
là-dedans on est là je suis président du
conseil d'administration l'école des
mines de nancy depuis maintenant neuf
ans
nous sommes le premier endroit où on
crée sur le même campus et on l'a
démarré l'année dernière sur le même
campus une école des mines une école de
commerce et une école de design et on
retrouve et on retrouve toujours
toujours retour vers le passé
l'école de nancy c'était quoi c'est
d'être capable de vendre des fontaines
qui était fait avec une technologie
absolument extraordinaire enfante un
design fantastique et d'être capable
d'aller les vendre aux fins
l'amérique latine où on y retrouve
toujours vous arrivez dans des villages
et vous êtes complètement stupéfait de
voir une fontaine française du 19e
siècle installé donc retrouver ce genre
de rapprochement d'hybridation me paraît
complètement clé donc c'est vrai dans
les secteurs c'est vrai dans les
formations
c'est vrai dans les gens donc des cils t
d si le thé je dirais notre notre
système éducatif notre système en
général je dois vous dire aussi des
grands sujets communs a beaucoup
beaucoup de vos interventions et de vos
avis oui je crois qu'on a besoin de
retrouver un état stratège
d'abord parce que nous sommes en
compétition avec d état stratège qui
pourraient prétendre que la chine n'est
pas un état stratège la corée le japon
ça c'est les états y atik me direz vous
la russie a réussi un état stratège les
pays du moyen-orient avec leurs fonds
souverains les états unis avec leurs
dépenses militaires et civils alors nous
alors même que ça a été notre force
historique on du ret90 nous on n'a pas
besoin de stratégies on a des normes et
contraintes réglementaires ça nous
suffit je crois que c'est vraiment une
erreur et je crois que vraiment il faut
qu'on retrouve le sens de la stratégie
alors notre grille il m'avait vous
demander et bien c'est à la fois le
commerce extérieur l'emploi la place de
la france dans le monde plan
géostratégique champion du monde
et puis dernière dimension l'acceptation
sociale parce que l'innovation
il faut qu'elle soit acceptée sa vie à
la célèbre histoire de l'anglais on cite
toujours le même anglais je m'excuse je
me souviens pas de son nom d'ailleurs
qu'elle s'est compliquée qui a inventé
la machine à tisser et qui a fait
fortune sont rôties il a eu un procès un
peu compliqué il a perdu à une nuit un
deuxième quelqu'un venait le chercher
sur son brevet y avait des copies etc
bref ça se passe à la fin du xviiie
siècle
pourquoi on des historiens ont découvert
qu'il y avait eu sept ou huit métiers à
tisser
avant donc il y avait eu sept ou huit
personnes qui avaient inventé avant lui
et qui avait inventé d'écologie tout à
fait équivalente ou même mieux pourquoi
cet homme a réussi parce qu'on était une
période de blocus et que la grande
bretagne avait absolument besoin de
retrouver des capacités de production et
donc la mécanisation devenait un must
donc l'innovation c'est la rencontre
effectivement de quelqu'un ou d'une
équipe qui a des idées
et puis d'une société qui est prêt à les
accepter donc la dimension de
l'acceptation sociale est aussi clé que
veulent vraiment les gens aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent en 2030
consommer mieux consommer différemment
avec l'idée par exemple qui émerge très
fort on a vécu dans les trente
glorieuses l'idée que la propriété des
choses étaient éléments tels éléments de
base
on est de plus en plus dans le fait bien
des usages
je partage je n'ai pas besoin forcément
d'être propriétaire donc cette évolution
doit nous amener aussi à réfléchir sur
nos modes de production sur des
quantités de production
on voit bien et sur l'envi alors je
voudrais réintroduire juste à ce moment
là d'ailleurs une idée simple qu'on
appelle l'innovation jugaad c'est un an
indien
c'est le fait d' innover en transformant
complètement l'objet je prends un
exemple simple bon en france
en france plus trop en france hélas en
allemagne dans quelques records
européens et aux états unis
beaucoup de gens travaillent sur comment
on va faire pour qu'un réfrigérateur par
là votre téléphone portable qui va
parler directement parce qu'ils manquent
de bouteilles de lait qu'on va vous les
livrer directement sans que vous ayez eu
quelque chose à dire et à faire ça c'est
le degré de sophistication conte à votre
réfrigérateur par là votre téléphone
portable qui parle à internet en inde
il n'y a pas d'électricité pour 700
millions de personnes donc un réfrigérée
et pourtant le pays et chou un
réfrigérateur ne peut pas fonctionner
électricité dans plein d'endroits ils
ont réinventé un réfrigérateur qui coûte
40 dollars et il utilise la chaleur la
condensation de l'eau sur la chaleur
pour créer du froid donc ils réinventent
quelque chose
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas ça
qui correspondra aux besoins des pays
développés mais c'est quand même
relativement formidable autre exemple
qui est très illustratif une couveuse
pour enfants prématurés
ces deux cent mille dollars c'est
formidable ça fait des tas de choses et
c'est là aussi dans beaucoup de pays
n'est pas question d'avoir une couveuse
à 200 mille dollars pour les enfants
prématurés qui sont pourtant nombreux
que faire bien il ya une jeune indienne
aux états unis à stanford qui a inventé
alors c'est un système assez compliqué
parce que ça utilise des ddd décompose
en un transfert de phase
vous mettez de l'eau bouillante dans un
espèce de petit truc qui ressemble c'est
ce qu'on met sur le ventre et par un
système assez subtil vous allez avoir
une température constante pour le bébé
pendant sept heures coup du sujet 20 $
donc l'innovation
alors ça c'est des exemples extrêmes
vous me direz pour pays en développement
oui il ya des tas de façons d'innover
qui font des objets plus simple enfin je
sais pas si vous avez tous l'expérience
je pense moi j'en suis incapable
entre la télévision le magnétoscope et
le lecteur de dvd
vous avez des télécommandes qui sont
devenus une complexité telle vous êtes
incapable de gérer l'ensemble des
données ces télécommandes enfin c'est un
quasiment un huguenot de l'a380 c'est
très énervant c'est très frustrant moyac
mes enfants qui savent parfaitement s'en
servir c'est encore plus agaçant pour
moi bon est ce qu'on a besoin de tout ça
non est-ce qu'on peut simplifier tout ça
donc innover par la simplification un
iphone c'est l'innovation par de la
simplification
donc je crois que cette application
apparente pour l'usager donc lusage le
côté facile d'usagé va devenir clé et ça
je pense que nous ne sommes pas
historiquement très fort en france là
dessus on est au contraire dans la
sophistication va rajouter encore un
truc en plus pour montrer qu'on est plus
fort que le voisin je crois que c'est un
peu dépassé
alors vous avez une question aussi qui
est revenu chez beaucoup d'entre vous
qui était mais finalement comment vous
allez vous organiser avec le système
existant vous interfacé avec les
ministères avec le cg le bon alors
d'abord on a essayé de faire que la
commission il est où les gens à
l'intérieur qui pourrait avoir un avis
grosso modo à l'extérieur je m'explique
dans le système administratif
nous avons le cg commissariat général à
l'investissement qui est membre de la
commission
nous avons la bpi directeur général qui
est membre de la commission
nous avons le commissaire jeudi au plan
moi c'est vrai que ces stratégies et
prospective j'ai un petit peu de mal à
dire ça nous avons erich huber qui est
membre du
cabinet de
d'arnaud montebourg qui assistent aux
séances
donc nous sommes nous avons thierry
mandon tête un député qui s'occupe de la
du budget de la r&d qui est aussi dans
le système
nous avons alain rousset qui représente
les régions dont on s'est dit voilà on
va avoir un intérieur de la commission
pour que nous puissions tous ensemble
avancé et que notre avancement soit
commun il nous manque qu'un sénateur je
serai ravi de d'accueillir une sénatrice
d'accueillir l'un d'entre vous nous
avons alors sur les grands sujets alors
sur les grands sujets vous nous avez dit
vous nous avez suggéré donc la mère
madame hervio monsieur reuver vous nous
avez suggéré l'énergie monsieur
pointereau monsieur revel nous a suggéré
aussi l'afrique
monsieur testant sur les pme
les grands groupes monsieur de noeuds
alors je vais te répondre point par
point alors sur les grands sujets - à
titre personnel je professe depuis
longtemps que les années à venir
c'est nous sommes dans un retour sur un
triangle de base les besoins de
l'humanité
l'eau la nourriture l'énergie et c'est
un triangle de plus en plus
interconnecté parce que pour faire la
nourriture il faut de l'eau et pour
faire de l'eau potable à partir du de
l'eau de mer il faut de l'énergie
donc ce triangle de base des besoins de
l'humanité il va se resserrer de plus en
plus sous la contrainte et je crois que
notre pays a des vraies chances dans ces
domaines dans l'énergie on a les
champions mondiaux dont l'eau et les
champions mondiaux et dans la nourriture
je crois pour n'est aussi parmi les
champions mondiaux
donc ça c'est ma conviction personnelle
à partir de là nous allons en discuter
et nous en discutons dans la dans la
commission de manière très large sur sur
la problématique de conforter les
secteurs existants
ça c'est un travail qui est fait
aujourd'hui par le ministère
du redressement productif en liaison
avec matignon
c'est le travail sur les filières alors
moi je partage à titre personnel ce que
vous dites
ce cas semble d'entre vous ont dit c'est
à dire que c'est vrai que ce qu'on n'a
pas su très bien faire historiquement en
france c'est savoir reconnaître quand
les sujets avec l'avenir ou pas c'est
vrai de certains secteurs mais c'est
aussi vrai au port plus je dirais de de
certaines implantations
on a soutenu à bout de bras des choses
qui n'avaient pas forcément d'avenir et
une partie de l'argent qu'ils auraient
du être dédiés à l'avenir a été
effectivement engloutis dans des
dépendants des des demandes et des
sujets qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup de ça
je pense le discernement entre les deux
sens cité saint françois d'assise
je pensais est indispensable qu'elle est
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises 150
millions d'euros c'est pas assez
cette décision de 150 millions d'euros
n'est pas la mienne donc j'ai le
sentiment qu'on doit pouvoir trouver
d'autres sources de financement et qu on
va essayer d'ailleurs aussi bien au
niveau européen qu'au niveau des
financements privés des financements
régionaux à trouver la façon
effectivement de mobiliser une partie
significative pour être efficace parce
qu'effectivement si on veut réussir sur
un ensemble de sujets il faut des tic
est quand même très significatif
vous avez beaucoup parlé
monsieur de noeuds
et ses successeurs sur l'éducation la
formation
oui je crois que la révolution des
systèmes d'information fait que
l'éducation va être transformé est-ce
que nous avons les moyens d'impulser ça
de l'extérieur on est quand même dans ce
thème éducation nationale
extraordinairement fort ça ça je ne sais
pas enfin partie des sujets qu'on
discute on va regarder d'ailleurs elle
beaucoup d'intérêt votre travail sur les
freins réglementaires à l'innovation au
niveau de l'office des risques comment
on fait pour que ça ne soit pas un
rapport de plus c'est un vrai sujet
quand vous accepté de présider une
commission c'est la question vous poser
d'abord est ce que vous dites oui en
disant que oui vous allez pouvoir faire
quelque chose où vous dites non en vous
disant soit les dés sont déjà pipés
soit ça va faire un classement vertical
écoutez je crois que l'idée ne sont pas
pipés et on va tout faire pour que ça ne
soit pas du classement vertical mais moi
j'ai besoin de vous pour
qu'effectivement on puisse on puisse
faire bouger le faire bouger les choses
monsieur hervé a parlé d' afrique comme
un sujet spécifique
moi je suis totalement d'accord c'est ça
me paraît un très grand sujet qui
s'ouvre qui se développe pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps
au moment où la france s'en
désintéressent et ce qui est
complètement paradoxal je crois qu'il ya
un énorme sujet africain
il est tout à fait raison c'est une de
nos ben voila je crois que les freak
l'afrique est en train de s'éveiller
donc que donner confiance en les chinois
en peul et on peut les battre
quand on le veut on n'est pas mauvais
alors vous mais beaucoup parlé
d'obstacles juridiques et fiscaux moi
j'ai envie de vous citer un sujet sur
lequel je vous je vous demande votre
secours
c'est par exemple big data dans le
numérique par pitié ne faisons pas de
lait nouvelle législation sur le sujet
avant de bien comprendre les tenants et
les aboutissants on a quand même un peu
le génie collectif français de légiférer
avant de connaître véritablement les
tenants et les aboutissants il faut
qu'on laisse le big data commencé à se
développer sans mettre une législation
qui va contraindre la cnil est déjà un
facteur de contraintes très fort je sais
il ya des gens qui ont des idées de
l'est de l'ihf légiférer là dessus je
crois que c'est vraiment trop tôt donné
confiance aux jeunes
bah je pense que c'est peut-être le
sujet majeur aujourd'hui le droit à
l'échec
le rapport à l'échec c'est vrai que
quand vous regardez comme embaucher un
jeune aux états unis et qu'il a fait une
start up et ça ça n'a pas marché
s'il est capable d'expliquer pourquoi ça
n'a pas marché on va considérer que
c'est un avantage considérable dans son
cv en france c'est un échec
ce garçon ou cette fille est déjà plombé
par son échec
alors on fait quelques progrès je sais
que la banque de france
nommé plus trois ans d'interdît bancaire
à toute personne ayant fait faillite
petit progrès donc ça veut dire qu'on
peut être effectivement redémarrer une
activité derrière mais ça reste ça reste
difficile
alors monsieur courteau et monsieur
mirassou ont parlé d' eads l'aviation
civile et de l'importance que ça
représentait pour notre pays j'en suis
très consciente puisque je suis au
conseil d'administration de ads
donc je suis ça en direct jeter la
semaine dernière à visiter l'a350 et
l'a400m sont des objets absolument
fantastique
on a des grands acteurs safran airbus
qui font énormément de r et d intégrer
alors comment ça se commence à se
concerte avec l'onera ou encore agba ça
c'est peut-être aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de ces entreprises intègrent de
plus en plus les choses
alors c'est vrai que les américains
aident beaucoup leurs recherches
on le voit enfin regarder ce qui est
devenu un airbus ces dernières années
airbus a aujourd'hui les parts de marché
mondiales pendant marche mondiale plus
importante que boeing sur un centre de
secteur et qui sont les clés
b c'est un petit peu alors je vais vous
dire c'est un tout petit peu normal pas
chez safran mais un tout petit peu
normal chez eads eads vient d'accoucher
de 3 à vue en même temps ce qui était
d'ailleurs deux fronts du jamais vu
l'a350 l'a400m l'a380 c'est bon on a vu
d'ailleurs que la diebolt la digestion
de l'objet n'a pas été très simple ils
vont pas développer un nouvel avion
demain matin parce qu'un avion ça dure
trente ans donc le l'idée c'est l a320
alors ces néo c'est pas mal née au 1a
palliatifs non au nom donne en est au
sepa palliatifs c'est vraiment des
réductions de bon alors mais je sors un
peu de mon en tout cas la bonne nouvelle
c'est que aujourd'hui eads a été capable
de rendre 3,5 milliards d'euros à ses
actionnaires donc est dans une situation
de santé financière qui lui permet de
faire face aussi non seulement à ces
développements mais des recherches plus
plus systématique et safran aussi 2010
c'est peut-être un peu normal si
effectivement sapristi lancé moi je sais
pas mais je n'ai pas su le double je
connais pas trop le sujet m'enfin je
pense que je suis pas très inquiète dit
long sur la r&d de l'aéronautique en
france civile aujourd'hui ni militaire
sur sur les hydroliennes
notez bien noté pas de problème
bon conforter les pme très petites
monsieur testant c'est pas avec les 150
millions d'euros pour y arriver donc ça
c'est une politique infiniment plus
vaste
c'est parfaitement clair qu'est-ce que
je tourne les feuilles monsieur fille
j'ai eu effectivement une traite il est
parti non il est là j'ai une très bonne
très bons souvenirs de ma vie de tld
mois les entreprises freinée par les
contraintes administratives
moi je serais très preneuse pour que
vous nous fassiez aussi remonté
justement ce que vous vous avez comme
comme demande comme problématique je
dirais les plus fortes qui vous
reviennent à travers les tissus
industriels et et d'entreprises que vous
avez donc vraiment là-dessus c'est fort
or je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
monsieur dantec sur sa vision du
nucléaire mais ça ne donnera peut-être
pas complètement je pense comme monsieur
guillaume surprise
je pense alors mais je pense comme vous
que quelque part il faut que nous
fassions des choix c'est à dire que le
non choix
le saupoudrage la dispersion le zapping
les changements de stratégie a vu un
ministre change c'est même pas des
alternances politiques c'est des
changements de ministres paf on change
tout c'est pas possible il faut qu on
essaye ensemble de savoir que
l'industrie la réussite économique c'est
le temps long la continuité la ténacité
et donc il faut pas pour continuer à
accepter que parce qu'un ministre arrive
il va falloir contrat de son
prédécesseur pour montrer sa différence
donc ça je crois que vous sénateurs qui
est là dans la continuité dans la force
dans la vision de long terme et je dois
dire et je dois dire en tant qu'ex
présidente d'areva
je ne saurais comment vous remercier
tous et toutes collectivement pour le
soutien que vous nous avez apporté à
travers les années à travers les années
il n'était pas là d'ailleurs on y est
pour rien et j'ai toujours dit que si je
cherchais très souvent l'état stratège
sans le trouver ici il ya une stratégie
et donc je crois que vous avez un rôle
mais considérable à jouer pour pousser
l'état
effectivement à avoir des boussoles et à
tenir c'est boussole
goûter on l'a encore vu ses jours oui
alors j'ai pas j'ai pas encore ni la
silver economy of j'en étais madame
madame hervio parle et il veut
économique nous recevons alors j'ai déjà
rencontré madame delaunay nous l'allons
l'auditionner cet après midi sur
justement qu'est ce que c'est que la
silver economy comment en faire un
secteur voilà donc ces partie des sujets
qu'on regarde à excuser moi et est
désolé de le dire il ya un pays qui est
en avance sur nous en reste dans une
situation démographique très grave c'est
le japon et qui est en train de
développer toute une industrie de la
robotique pour effectivement pallier le
manque de jeunes générations donc ça
c'est un la dimension européenne
monsieur dantec avait l'air de dire il
faut faire confiance à la gouvernance
européenne aux avec dantec dont la
gouvernance européenne choix que
justement elle a besoin d'être un tout
petit peu améliorée dans ces domaines et
là aussi on aimerait bien voir une
europe stratège et on voit que les
grands groupes industriels pour 10
européen ils sont pas européen eads ces
quatre pays et je crois que c'est un
modèle moderne c'est prendre quelques
pays qui ont une envie commune vision
politique et des grands industriels qui
sont d'accord pour fusionner moi
j'appelle par exemple à faire d'airbus
du renouvelable
je pense qu'il serait beaucoup plus
intelligent de d'apporter à trois ou
quatre pays qui font aujourd'hui du
renouvelable en europe nos activités
industrielles
notre politique d'ensemble et qu'on soit
en compétition avec general electric
après mitsubishi ou les autres mais en
tout cas dans une structure qui est
renforcer il faut sortir de l'isolément
et non taillé sur un ensemble de sujets
on est trop petit voilà et j'ai pas
répandu un gaz de schiste alors gaz de
schiste ça c'est un peu mon autre
casquette je suis membre du comité de
pilotage du débat sur la transition
énergétique
moi je trouve je les dis je ne vais pas
cacher je le redis et je crois que le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas un accord sur le
sujet va être actée je pense que dans le
pays des cartes et de montaigne arriver
à se battre sur un sujet qu'on n'est
même pas à les mesurer
me paraît assez étonnant pour ne pas
dire incroyable donc allé faire un
inventaire des gaz de schiste que nous
avons que nous avons pas le parent est
un préalable
la deuxième dimension c'est que si on
veut développer des technologies propres
et je crois qu'on a tout à fait les
moyens de le faire entre l'ifp et le
brgm
total gdf suez on a toutes sortes de
grands acteurs pour le faire on ne peut
le faire qu'avec des expérimentations on
va on peut pas tout faire en labo donc
des expérimentations extrêmement
contrôlée de m oui donc je pense qu'il
nous faut à la fois faire un inventaire
et des expérimentations et qu'il serait
complètement absurde de pas de pas se
lancer là dedans ça c'est mon opinion
personnelle
pardon ça sera je l'espère dans le
rapport
et puis dernière question que me posais
le président ce pardon à sanofi alors
sanofi je ne suis pas très compétente
donc je ne sais pas exactement je sais
que l'industrie pharmaceutique en
général à a complètement changé et de
tout
pratiquement toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique parce que sa recherche
interne
il a jugé pas assez productive
généralement axés sur le chimique
ils se sont complètement changer de
système et ils rachètent des startups en
particulier d'ailleurs venant de la du
biologique venant de mariage entre
biologie et data aux dépens de leurs
grands labos qui avait enflé avec le
temps alors je suis incapable de donner
un jugement sur le bien-fondé ce qui va
être perdu moi je suis toujours un tout
petit peu sceptique sur les grands
mouvements les grandes embardées brutale
donc est ce qu a supprimé des labos
comme ça brutalement on supprime des
choses on m'a pas les recréer overnight
je pense qu'il ya une perte quand même
dû compétences qui un jour ou l'autre à
préjudiciable alors c'est vrai qu'en
même temps quand on voit les grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques mondiaux
alors qu'ils avaient des nouveaux
produits en diminution constante
ils sont à nouveau avec une augmentation
des produits qui arrivent sur le marché
pas nos actionnaires ceux-ci explicable
parfois cela ça c'est un standard du
marché donc alors sur les imprimantes 3d
je reviendrai un petit peu de questions
que me pose est le président et j'ai
envie de terminer un peu sur acceptation
sociétale
on est quand même dans une problématique
collective qui est on le voit d'ailleurs
avec tout ce qui est sorti sur des
lanceurs d'alert les les problématiques
des coûte
on voit qu'on est dans une espèce de
révolution technologique ou comme vous
lisez tout à l'heure on a une masse de
données disponibles absolument
extraordinaire sur des terminaux ou très
simple qui se parlent entre eux et en
même temps un énorme problème de liberté
et de contrôle et qui va aller croissant
c'est à dire que parce que vous aurez
fait telle dépense dans tel endroit on
va savoir que vous avez tel profil et
pitel bon et puis on définit votre
profil et donc on va vous envoyer telle
information est donc il ya une forme
effectivement je pense qui correspond
bien à notre pays des droits de l'homme
il ya certainement une façon de gérer
toutes ces technologies différentes
comment la gérer avec
je dirais liberté égalité fraternité ça
je pense que c'est aussi un gisement
comment on fait pour que l'on puisse
développer toutes ces nouvelles
technologies en respectant les libertés
individuelles
sans ça me paraît un élément clé on
s'aperçoit aussi que nos concitoyens
de plus en plus se méfie de la science
et de la technologie les
nanotechnologies les ogm on voit quand
même des courants sujets qui sont pas
faciles à faire rentrer avec des
conséquences fortes parce que regarder
les ogm
ça veut dire qu'on a quand même perdu
une partie du leadership qu'on avait
dans le domaine agroalimentaire donc
tout ça nous oblige à réfléchir aussi à
comment on prépare les esprits
c'est un peu paradoxal parce que
l'innovation est souvent brutale elle
arrive comme ça
mais comment on prépare les esprits
comment fait que contrairement au gaz de
schiste on n'arrive pas une interdiction
en quinze jours sans études sans analyse
sans pour et contre
alors moi j'ai un slogan personnel et je
crois que je vais m en frontispice
d'entre eux rapport c'est que le
principe de précaution doit être
équilibré par le principe d'innovation
et bien voilà on vit très bien
en matière de valeur ajoutée parmi les
27 pays européens en 24e position
sur quelles statistiques vous
appuyez-vous ça vient de re stats donc
les et les statistiques européennes etc
la part de la valeur ajoutée
industrielle a rapportées au pnb alors
je n'ai pas répondu à mon cher
stagiaires donc très récent naître sous
péridurale les morses palliatifs c'est
dur moi je fais la différence entre
l'effort et la douleur on n'a pas besoin
de souffrir et franchement moi j'ai
accouché sous péridurale et je trouve
que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
par contre les forts rui les forces et
pas la douleur est montrée justement que
l'effort il ya un bonheur dans l'effort
je crois que c'est ça une dimension
éducative qui est complètement
voilà les formes et sans douleur mais
bonjour et ça va ça va de paire avec la
reconnaissance du savoir des chercheurs
des innovateurs par la société ce qui
n'est pas vraiment le cas aujourd'hui
sur l'énergie j'ai envie de vous
répondre de manière très précise
attention il ya une grosse différence
entre décentralisation et mutualisation
moi je vois émerger partout sur les
territoires l'idée que vont être des
systèmes énergétiques décentralisées
intermittents qui vont fonctionner quand
il ya du soleil quand il ya du vent etc
mais c'est pas grave parce que quand il
n'y a pas de soleil a pas devant il ya
un système national qui va arriver
qu'ils aiment de l'électricité alors
peut-être qu'on est allé une
centralisation historique et de ses
cibles
mais cette centralisation est une
mutualisation des intérêts
si on est dans une décentralisation
totale moi je voyais hier des régions
qui annonçait 45% de renouvelables dans
leur mix énergétique 45% intermittents
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans
les 55 % du temps autres c'est le
système national qui fonctionne mais
s'il fonctionne pas 45% dans cette
région à 55% il est plus rentable
donc on a créé un système qui a coûté
très cher et qui est collectivement non
rentables donc je crois qu'il faut dans
l'énergie avoir toujours le souci de
l'intérêt général et pas être uniquement
centré sur son sujet à soi et son
système perso et ça je pense que c'est
un élément clé et garder la
compétitivité de l'énergie française ses
clés on a une des énergies les moins
chers d'europe
il faut absolument garder cette voie là
et sur les français qui s'exporte
oui mais il faudrait qu'ils seraient
importe aussi c'est bien d'aller faire
un petit tour à l'étranger mais il faut
qu'ils reviennent
nous remercions madame pour cette longue
audition merci pour toutes ces idées non
mais relevé que vous cherchez un
sénateur est donc une sénatrice pardon
et puis que nous devons occasion très
bien vous venez d'écouté l'audition au
d'anne lauvergeon la présidente de la
commission innovation en 2030 elle était
entendu par les commissions à des
affaires économiques et du développement
durable du sénat si vous souhaitez
revoir cette audition elle est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne journée à
tous